se espera que esta investigación sea
publicada en su totalidad la próxima
semana a finales de enero primeros días
de febrero se había revelado una primera
parte que dejaba mal parado al gobierno
por esa cultura promovida de romper la
ley si el resultado es malo para el
primer ministro entonces podría
enfrentar una moción de confianza de su
partido que podría dejarlo al borde de
la salida de dawn instruir pero no
olvidemos que johnson también enfrenta
una investigación del parlamento
británico para establecer si mintió o no
a la cámara de los comunes sobre si
rompió o no la ley lo que es aún mucho
más grave así que días complicados para
el primer ministro pero lo cierto es que
los partidos de oposición están
insistiendo en que johnson debe irse de
simplemente por el hecho de haber roto
la ley en una oportunidad